every few months or so I look at my
social content and ask myself what can I
do to get people to share it more I'll
think about marketing by having a
stronger call to action or promoting on
Twitter more or reaching out to
influencers I'll think about SEO and
improving my title subscriptions
playlists and tags I'll think about
analytics and looking at what my best
performing videos are and how it can
replicate that success on and on all of
that helps but it's a small game the
real thing that I keep coming back to is
that the content I'm making just needs
to get better it's not some trick or
tactic that I'm missing it just needs to
get better want to know the biggest
secret to getting someone to share your
content give them something they
actually want to share give them
something so good that they instalike it
and instacare it and that sucks because
that's a lot of hard work because it
would be great to think that there is
one magic little thing that I just need
to do and if I do that everything will
get so much better but there isn't so if
you're frustrated that your content
isn't getting enough shares views or
likes you can look at your marketing SEO
analytics or whatever other magic
solution you think is out there but it's
all a small game the big win isn't just
making better content go do that and
you'll win
[Music]